ما عاد السؤال هل بل متى فعل خط النار
تلتهب احتمالات تنفيذ الاتراك عمليه
عسكريه بريه في الشمال السوري
لا تخفي مصادر الرسميه تركيه اكتمال ما
تقول انها التحضيرات العسكريه واللوجستيه
اللازمه لتنفيذ تلك العمليه
حتى تحين اللحظه يكثف الجيش التركي ضغط
على فصائل كرديه المسلحه بمواصله استهداف
مواقعها انه الاصرار على تحيد من تراهم من
قرا خطرا على
امنهار فنحن في تركيا شعبا ودوله والحمد
لله قادرون على مكافحه الارهاب في شمال
سوريا كما قمنا بذلك في سوريا وفي العراق
وفي اي مكان اخر في العالم ورغم ان بعض
الحلفاء يقدمون تصريحات تدعمون في شمال
سوريا فانهم يطلبون منا امورا لا يمكن
قوله لها ليست هواجس الحلفاء وحدهم فالقلق
غالب على المواقف الدوليه من خطوه تركيه
قد تعرض الاستقرار الاقليميه للخطر هنا
يطمئن الاتراك بان عملياتهم العسكريه تنفذ
بشكل دقيق ضد وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
في شمال سوريا ومن دون اي تهديد
سلامه القوات الامريكيه والروسيه
يخشى الامريكيون مع ذلك من ان اجتياح
البريا سيبدل ماء الجزاء في قتال تنظيم
الدوله
لكنهم يبدون التفاهم لما خاوي في تركيا
الامنيه حيال الاعمال الارهابيه داخل
حدودها
المساله برمتها يكشف البنتاجون ان وزير
الدفاع لويد اوستن سيبحثها هاتفيا عما
قريب مع نظيره التركي خلص يا اكار لكن اين
الروس من كل ذلك
صحيح ان الجدل انتعش حول مدى التزامهم
باتفاقيه سوتشي لكنهم دخلوا على خط الازمه
المستجده لمحاوله احتوائها يبدو ان موسكو
سمعت من انقار اشتراطاتها للعدول عن
العمليه العسكريه البريه في الشمال السوري
واضح ان الاتراك لن يرضوا باقل من حل
الوحدات الكرديه او اخراجها من مناطق
النفوذ الروسي ووقف محاولتها للتسلل الى
تركيا على ان تعود مؤسسات النظام السوري
بما فيها القوات الامريكيه وحرس الحدود
بديلا عما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
سيشكل ذلك كله تحديا لمساعد الروس لتهدئه
الاوضاع فاي عرض سيقدمونه ينبغي ان يلبي
مطالبه تركيا